AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, GAME
DOODY STENCH.
A FUN FACT ABOUT DONALD TRUMP --
I'M GLAD THERE IS ONE --
HE'S THE FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE TO HAVE HIS OWN LINE
OF FRAGRANCES, ONE OF THE MANY
WAYS YOU CAN TELL THAT HE SHOULD
NOT BE PRESIDENT.
IN CASE YOU UNDERESTIMATED WHAT
AN ASSHOLE HE IS, ONE OF THE
FRAGRANCES IS CALLED "SUCCESS."
IT'S AN INSPIRING BLAND OF JET
FUEL, CAT[BEEP] AND NANNY TEARS.
SO YOU CAN SMELL LIKE A
QUESTIONABLY MASCULINE
APOCALYPSE.
OH, IT'S [BLEEP] COLORED.
WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING IT ON SHOULD
YOU BE LIKE THIS? SUCCESS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: COMEDIANS I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU A PHOTO OF A SO-CALLED
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE,
AND I WANT YOU TO DESCRIBE
WHAT THEIR FRAGRANCE WOULD
SMELL LIKE, OKAY?
FIRST ONE, I'M GONNA START THE
CLOCK NOW. LET'S GO.
OKAY, MIKE LAWRENCE.
>> THE GARBAGE CAN HE LIVES IN
ON SESAME STREET.
>> Chris: NEXT UP TED CRUZ.
>> GAY PORN AND CHIN CANKLES.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: CHIN CANKLES.
POINTS. NEXT UP, MARCO RUBIO.
ASHLEY.
>> BASIC BITCH FOR MEN.
Chris: POINTS.
NEXT HILLARY CLINTON, MIKE
LAWRENCE.
>> LOVELESS MARRIAGES HAVE NO
SMELL.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JEB BUSH, MIKE
LAWRENCE.
>> THE SMELLIEST BUSH IN ALL OF
FLORIDA.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: THERE'S MORE?
>> AND I KNOW BECAUSE I WAS BORN
IN FLORIDA.
Chris: ALRIGHT POINTS TO MIKE
LAWRENCE.